one more drink one more
drink you know in the morning
for sure we gonna stink one more
round one more round
it's
this is what we do catch up for a few
we'll riff and talk some [ __ ] and then
we'll sleep till two
[Music]
hey we might be drunk it's [ __ ] 3 p.m
on super bowl sunday this is our first
early one
yes we're finally moving on to day
drinking which is the next step of
alcoholism
what are you drinking i'm dying to know
what you drink during the day
well i figured super bowl sunday i'm in
new orleans seeing my mom on
her birthday she's uh she's 25. happy
birthday mrs norman
i'm i'm going uh
bloody mary whoa dude
no way no way look at that
the official day drink great day drink a
little vodka here
yeah and uh i'm gonna do it up i threw i
threw a [ __ ]
spicy pickle up in that [ __ ] i'm
jealous i wish i had a couple of little
accoutrements or whatever you call it
what do you go to for a bloody mary like
what it what's an appropriate garnish
what takes it too far
oh good question well in new orleans
there's all these psychos who put a
[ __ ]
crab leg in there and a shrimp tail and
a lamb
but they always they always go too far
it's like a katrina version the whole
kitchen sinks in there you know it's
like a prosthetic leg
but i i think uh green olive
celery maybe an okra and uh some white
onion
how about a pickle's not okay no well
pickle's good pickle's good
i like a pickle i even i even throw some
pickle juice up in that [ __ ]
dude i'm
crazy good i like a little pickle juice
with booze i i was pro pickle back from
the get-go
oh yeah pickleback had a renaissance
that that really
popped they [ __ ] it died out like
[ __ ] uh
what's the one what's the what was that
uh
nut cronut that's what it was i was
thinking of uh
zima zemo was the one i was thinking
about zima had a minute and then it was
like
peace bye zema that was like how you
described a guy as a [ __ ]
that was like for like the guy who was
like homophobic but couldn't say that so
he'd be like
what are you a zima drinker and you're
like she's chill out right
zema crystal pepsi and the macarena in
and out
well crystal pepsi made no sense
i i thought it was cool i mean it was
clear i'm like it used to be brown now
it's clear but nobody nobody dug it
but it's just [ __ ] but now he said
but you've got another clear drink that
you're peddling with seven up why are we
doing why are we doing now it's just
confusing i don't know
yeah good point and and nobody gives a
[ __ ] you know
it's just the same drink just clear so
yeah i get it
but white claw when it first came out
it was like this [ __ ] drink it was a
lemon truly you know
and after a while people were like look
[ __ ] you i'm a [ __ ] i'm drinking it
and then they just owned it and it kind
of got garnered or
what's the word garnered in
grandfathered in grandfathered it yeah i
think
you know what happened it got james
garnered in it was a [ __ ] it was a
cool ass
no it uh you know
i think that was robert wagner wasn't it
oh geez sorry but also he
he didn't they like he didn't do it but
like right
yeah natalie wood man [ __ ] oh
pretty lady pretty lady went out went
out [ __ ]
at sea that's how you're gonna die i
know
i know and that was back when you can
get away with a murder you know that was
pre-dna
pre-cell phone cam free all that [ __ ]
dna pre-dna is like uh
it was [ __ ] just anyone it was like
steroids in baseball it's like no one
when no one gave a [ __ ] you could just
put up numbers
you know what i mean that's so true you
know you watch these unsolved mysteries
it's almost like a cell phone in a
horror movie like back in the day there
were no cell phones so you know
he's in the house ah and now it's just
like i just call the police or i'll be
at the log cabin i'll call the fire
depart whatever it is
and back in the day you're just screwed
well you nailed it because they remade
rear window with shia labeouf they
called it disturbia
and the whole thing about rear window is
that she goes across the street to the
murderous place and he can't reach her
he's screaming like
get out get out but in disturbia he's
like ah she's got
she must have no service
[Laughter]
yeah they have to have a scene where the
cell phone breaks or it falls in a lake
you know just to get through the plot
that's a good that's your t-mobile ad
right there you should have switched to
a t
right right you got murdered grace kelly
died
yeah she fought another one that died
young car crash
really married like the prince of monaco
or something and yeah and she died in a
car crash like 50 or something [ __ ]
horrible
beautiful woman beautiful i mean all
those people went out like fatty
arbuckle was young and uh
marilyn monroe was the overdose all
those hot ladies they were not
they were smoking cigarettes at nine
they were only allowed to drink coffee
and smoke cigarettes they couldn't gain
weight i mean it was a rough life for a
young starlet like the 40s
that's so true yeah marilyn monroe was
just like so [ __ ] tiny
like she just like i bet if you saw her
in person now you'd be like that's like
a little person that's
she was so small and uh banging joe
dimaggio so not when she's small but
she's probably [ __ ]
catching some abuse that was an angry
dude
i think he i think sinatra's like [ __ ]
all his friends girl
yeah yeah he wasn't a great guy i bet i
mean
you've seen uh the kid stays in the
picture where he's like he's banging
uh what's up mia faro
dude that's like [ __ ] weird too he
was 61 and she was 20.
i know what do you talk about yeah
what do you what do you like
you're looking for depends she's looking
for [ __ ] uh i don't know 61
61 sinatra is [ __ ] rough too that's
not like a regular 60. that's not like a
[ __ ] dwayne
johnson 61. that's a vodka martini
i'm getting [ __ ] hammered i don't
sleep and i eat rib eyes every night
61. yeah that's a two pack a day scotch
drinking
uh you know italian [ __ ] italian
jersey guy
crooner you know yeah you're right
that'll wear on you plus nobody was
eating kale back then
or or you know doing [ __ ] uh
meditating or
zumba so yeah that's a bad bad
when rickles was the healthy one in your
group
ah you hockey [ __ ]
dude uh [ __ ] sinatra really uh yeah
apparently a manic depressive
terrible yeah but he also he [ __ ] his
friends women like he
uh when bogey was dying he was like like
uh you're my boy bogey and then
immediately moves in on lauren bacall
ava gardner yeah oh dude he [ __ ] i
mean no one's no one's saying he didn't
have game
wow uh what's her name that was some
starlet back then
she said sinatra was the best sex of her
life but she was it was so
it was in the 40s and 50s so she said in
an interview
you couldn't be vulgar so she said oh my
god he's amazing in the feathers
which i thought was such a great cool
line for this
this [ __ ] to like cover it up you know
the feathers
and the feathers [ __ ] so noir i love
they all had to talk
it was better writing back then because
they had to avoid that stuff we could
just say [ __ ] whenever we want so we can
get lazy
yeah so true i mean i did the tonight
show and i used to say like
something or other and i had to change
it to go clean i wish i knew what it was
but it was so much more clever
because i had to make it clean and it
sort of makes me get creative
it does it works both ways because i
remember griffin our buddy on letterman
i might have said this on our podcast
even but he
he had a joke like you know young women
are filled with sugar and spice and
everything nice and i'm filled with
anger and semen and shame
and they made him change semen to prozac
and i'm like [ __ ] semen's so much
funnier you got the illiterate
yeah so it works those suits don't help
us but i do think when we force
ourselves to
to have to come up with a more clever
line you know yeah yeah yeah that's true
it can go both ways
totally but yeah yeah sinatra apparently
i made did you watch the doc on hbo
about him
now i read a book by earl wilson who was
like a new york post writer back in the
day
i never i never saw the doc is it great
it's pretty great just cause like how
different things are like he was italian
back in the day and you couldn't you
know you got in trouble if you were
italian his dad had to change the name
of his bar to o'leary's just to seem
irish
just so he could keep it open like crazy
[ __ ] about italian
discrimination that's [ __ ] weird
yeah he would just get really drunk and
be like he had a jet
obviously you know he's the most on the
planet and he'd be like let's just fly
to london they're like dude it's five
and he's let's go to bed he's like let's
fly to london just couldn't stop
well that was like a power thing back
then i mean the song come fly with me is
like that was a status thing
come fly with me now it's like all right
you want to go fly somewhere but like
back then it was like
come fly with me i'll we'll float down
to peru and they'd be like oh my god
peru
you know right that's a great point and
all these cool little stories about like
stand-up comedy you call it stand-up
comedy because the mob
ran all the nights clubs and the gin
joints and they'd say
this is a stand-up guy he's good he's a
stand-up guy and that's where his
stand-up comedian came from
interesting yeah and also vegas when the
mob ran it it seemed to
work much more smoothly it seemed smooth
even though they're murderers and
psychopaths it kind of
worked if you bail on the movie casino
before that last scene it seems all
right i don't know
right before uh pesci and and phil
vincent
frank vincent would ever get [ __ ]
that's one of the toughest watch scenes
ever
oh when he's watching his brother get
pounded and then then they throw his fat
body with the tidy whities into the
ditch and they hit him with bat ah
god it's too much he's like one of the
toughest three one of the toughest
scenes
brutal brutal but fun movie that's a
movie you can just put on
keep on you're making eggs in the
background you're watching casino they
got a guy's hand in a vice it's great
i mean which hand do you deal with james
woods playing the sleaziest [ __ ]
yeah so so good in that movie oh man
he's so
what is it lester diamond something like
that yeah sharon stone's just hot as
[ __ ] in that movie too
so hot good actress yeah so good yeah
that scene where uh she blows pesky
she's crying on his shoulder he's like i
know i know
i mean come on i was 14 like jesus
what's going on here yeah patchy's a
piece of [ __ ] but you're also like well
well done peshy it's one of those weird
moments where like he's a bad friend but
like i didn't expect pat should be
pulling sharon stone so
i know i give him a little bit of a nod
right right and
apparently all true story and all that
based on a true story pretty amazing
it is weird where like mob type dudes
draw the line
you know because they're like i mean i'm
obsessed with the sopranos and like
it is funny how they're like justify
[ __ ] we're like this is horrible this is
[ __ ] up but then like what they'll be
like
pedophile we don't [ __ ] do that we
just murder people and you're like all
right but you're still like a bad dude
yeah that isn't i mean prison's the same
way you know they're all
murderers and rapists but then when a
pedophile comes in they're like this
guy's a bad apple
yeah that's true it's made off in prison
got a lot of respect
like this dude [ __ ] he he robbed people
blind for for decades this [ __ ]
he walks in everyone's like i'm sure it
gets old i'm sure he preferred
being in a brownstone and
[Laughter]
i mean it's look i get it i mean it's
cruel and he's robbing people and he's a
criminal but like
there's something badass about about
doing crime
with a suit on and not getting your
hands dirty
exactly i mean if you're in there for a
vehicular like some sort of like car
robbery or something and then you meet
this guy and you're like well this guy's
the king
you know yes yes he did it from an ivory
tower while getting a bj
and rubbing a cat you know and these
other guys are on their hands and knees
under a car stealing a catalytic
converter
way cooler you know what's crazy he's
like the peak of
what a criminal can be and it still
ended horribly for i mean didn't one of
his kids kill himself i mean
it was [ __ ] bad i think oh is that
right i didn't i'm pretty sure one of
his kids commit suicide
oh i'm double checking here but also
two things maybe i'm how perfect is the
name
isn't that weird when a name is so made
off he made and then you got anthony
weiner that's another perfect one
how great is that that's just like a
gift from the comedy gods
did you see the wiener doc yo i saw it
wait
that's just gay porn yeah yeah i've seen
that that's
right [ __ ] incredible dude decent
piece on that guy as well
i was i don't remember that part oh yeah
yeah and he had kind of a good
actually you know i do remember a little
bit because that jim underwear shot and
he's in good shape too he's like
he looks like he looks like a string
bean but then you're like oh this dude
works it out
oh yeah he's got like the fight club
shredded skinny
muscle what a waste of the v
ab you know
yeah body i mean he [ __ ] pulled huma
who was
hot and is that right accomplished yo
you know his wife is you know he
he married her she was hot and uh oh i
thought you said uma thurman
no no no huma uh clinton aide
uh no she was she's in the dock she's
super hot
and successful and uh clearly
put up with a lot yeah to say the least
yeah
she got that from hillary too she's like
we as women have to deal with a lot and
they're like all right i mean
he he had so many chances as mayor
and as a husband and he i mean the part
was so [ __ ] funny
is uh i saw that in the theaters in new
york and there's that scene where they
have a jon stewart clip
and it's they play the clip in borough
park
where someone says something
anti-semitic like
if they you just show weiner losing his
[ __ ] on some orthodox jew and everyone's
like oh what a lunatic but then
before and some orthodox juice has
something really [ __ ] up about him
being with an arab
and it comes to it goes i take it back
[ __ ] him and it got an applause break on
the daily show
and in the theater got an applause break
ah and you're like damn jon stewart
kills so hard
that he's killing in a theater yes
wow how how interesting is that that
it's like hey he's a he's a racist
or a bigot and then the person who calls
you a bigot turns out to be bigoted
isn't that crazy it's human nature you
know we all do it
and also we that's the internet too is
like we're so quick to jump on someone
who [ __ ] up but then it's like okay but
we just saw where they lost their mind
let's can we see what happened before
right exactly can we challenge the play
like a football game can we challenge
this cancellation or whatever this is
yes
yes but they don't want to check cause
they just want as bill marvel said they
want the scalp on the wall they don't
actually care about the justice they
just want to
get you that's interesting yeah well i
mean but then also
if it's not too serious they tend to
move on i mean that's the nature of the
internet too is like if you just ignore
it they they run away usually they move
on they move on to the next shiny
yes exactly it's uh it's interesting you
say burro park because i used to
i had a i guess hasidic landlord and i'd
have to go pay him and bro he made me go
out to borough park which is like a
million miles into brooklyn
it's all hasidic it's all hebrew
everything yeah like you'd see
like a hebrew like a guy in a jewish
outfit with the with the tassels
and the curls like hammering on a
building you're like what the [ __ ] it's
so weird to see a jewish
guy building stuff or like doing a buzz
saw you know
and it's just weird to see you don't see
a lot of jewish people
hey no like you guys like land cement
whether it be the yamacon it's just bad
i bet you differ we have the most famous
jewish carpenter of all time
i haven't seen much of his work to be
honest that's fair i don't know where
the jewish the
jesus cabinets are but uh
no i know what you mean i i used to go
to like i used to tutor kids in like uh
south williamsburg and when i'd leave
late at night i'd be like oh this is
[ __ ] weird late at night
because you see a lot of shady looking
characters
right right definitely yeah so
they knew right away i wasn't part of
the tribe because i remember one time i
walked in
to borough park area and i'm lost and i
see a guy a jewish guy on the corner i
go hey man which way is 14th street and
he looks me up and down and goes
i don't know i go half a block i hit
14th street i was like that [ __ ]
wow yeah he looked you up and down there
is
you know as a jew i'm i'm i'm a cultural
jew i'm not a religious jew so i'm more
of an avoidant jew i'm not like the type
well there's a type in the street
they're like are you jewish and they're
like they're trying to get you to sign
up for something and you're just like
yeah but i'm i'm like a jew who keeps to
myself i'm like i'm not the
i'm not signing i'm trying i'm not
trying to get on more email lists you
know what i mean
right yeah exactly i don't want to be
part of the prayer circle or the
synagogue or whatever the [ __ ]
yeah and they know i mean you kind of
have a jewish vibe though i mean you you
i think a lot of it is like you grew up
with so much comedy and so many
comedians are jewish
yeah so there's like almost like a
jewish sensibility in you a little bit
i don't know yeah sure i mean i think as
a comment i'm a wannabe i mean like
larry david
and seinfeld and adam sandler groucho
marx woody allen like i'm obsessed with
all these jewish guys
um plus every time you go who what's is
that guy jewish he's really funny they
usually say yeah like mel brooks and
mort saul and it just keeps going like
shelly man whatever it is
a lot of people don't even know who mort
saul is now yeah that's true that's true
woody allen's idol by them
you know what's interesting about about
march saul i i saw someone write
something about this how if
he died and lenny bruce went on he would
have been lenny bruce
because if you die in your prime you
know i mean think about who the most
famous rappers of all time are it's
tupac and biggie it's the two guys who
died in their [ __ ] 20s
you know about the reverence we have for
bill hicks or people who die
super young edberg geraldo geraldo yeah
geraldo was in his 40s but he was like
just getting to that prime where he was
yeah
[ __ ] good i mean like look at che
guevara we talk about i think we've
talked about this but like
the people that become iconic we talked
about the last episode but like
mort saul was like the guy he was like
john oliver john stewart back in the day
yeah and i just got old and i guess it
just stopped working i don't know
yeah well i mean first again just go
back to the jewish thing mort's all jon
stewart lenny
joan rivers all jews but it's john
liebowitz by the way his
room that's right a little offensive
that he changed it you know come on
buddy
stick with the group but i get it it's
hollywood but
i don't know if mort saul and we're
going deep comedy stuff here
of mort saul had the cajones like lenny
bruce was a twisted guy you know heroin
addict
you know weirdo a little bit he had the
the hutzpah
to like push the system i don't know if
mort saul was trying to rock the boat i
mean
he had some great points and he was
political but i think
you need a little bit of a psycho to go
say [ __ ] in the 50s
in a coffee shop and get pulled out by
cops that's that's well said and also to
like be a druggie and like kind of like
a hard edge badass and leather jacket
you're kind of like oh you're like a
[ __ ]
you're like a you're trying to shake it
up a little bit yes
yes joan rivers said he made comedy sexy
wow yeah that's [ __ ] cool not you
know you look at shelly berman or mel
brooks they're not exactly sexy guys
yeah but look who mel brooks married
though ah
good point bancroft yeah i mean like
funny funny can be cool man
right and he was in world war ii by the
way don't forget that
yeah these [ __ ] are such like
we think about like men i saw this
article on
tom brady and uh
it was just him it was like on him he
did a thing on jimmy kimmel show where
they read mean tweets a funny segment
like
gives people an opportunity to be a
little self-deprecating and
he's reading these tweets and they're
like you're not a man you can't use a
wrench
and uh tom brady's like yeah i mean
you're kind of right you know
it's like funny but it's like well
what's a man it's like the dude is like
the greatest football player ever
yeah you're not a [ __ ] man you can't
usually
guess what he's so successful he never
had to learn how
exactly yes i'm banging a supermodel i
got six super bowl rings
i'm a millionaire i provide i'm a best
player
what do you want from me yeah he's a
[ __ ]
i i wonder if it's i mean i'm sure it's
enjoyable the accolades and being just
like
beyond loved by everyone everyone's like
you're the [ __ ] greatest i saw that
rapper uh
french montana put 250k on the super
bowl my god damn
wow imagine that but uh you know
everyone [ __ ] loves brady man and it
everyone at least respects him yes yes
yeah
maybe they hate him or because he's so
good
yeah i mean and also like i think like
whenever someone when you're just being
fed consciously this guy's the goat this
guy's the greatest
people are like shut the [ __ ] up right
he is i mean it's like
i think and it's another thing it's like
when he retires i think people will love
him even more
because they'll really take in the
greatness it's like mj like in his prime
i [ __ ] hated mj in the 90s i was a
knicks fan
but like you can't look back on jordan
and not be like you're the [ __ ]
you're not the [ __ ] he's the shorts he's
the [ __ ] he's the guy
he's the best and it's just what we do
in this country we like to bring you up
and then take you down and uh
but death is the ultimate down so once
you go to death you're back up again
it's this weird [ __ ] system and it's
all based on insecurity and ego
and let me just say this about the jews
it's the last thing
you gotta have some weird jewish
chosen people hebrew pride for
because there's some jewish bad guys out
there but they're the best at being bad
guys
madoff is the best at what he did
epstein
obviously a villain but
killed it i mean who had more uh ladies
on a conveyor belt well uh
to go against what you're saying they
weren't ladies
females i guess no i mean epstein is uh
i mean yeah he made it to the top for
sure i mean he was a sneaky [ __ ]
uh yeah weird that he was a teacher at
dalton
yeah yeah weird that he was uh
yeah i mean smart dude
i'm not like i'm not defending what the
guy did but it's like the micro scene
joke you know where they go this guy
is the worst pedophile he molested 500
kids and you're like
actually he's the best pedophile yes
that's [ __ ] brilliant basically
mike's brilliant joke where he's like
the worst pedophile that's a guy who
can't get his van to start
he's giving kids wnba cards his candy is
circus peanuts
[ __ ] that's a brilliant joke
brilliant it's got the best tags of all
time if you guys want a great album
check out mike racine's album it's
itunes spotify r-e-c-i-n-e
micro scene [ __ ] incredibly funny
incredible so many great jokes uh but
yeah no i mean look that peak villain i
guess so yeah i guess they i guess
epstein was
harvey weinstein another peak jew
villain
you guys just do you guys what you do is
what i'm saying
yeah you know it could be for good or
could be for bad
you're going to the top you know what's
weird about weinstein is his real last
name is steward
but he changed it uh no
harvey weinstein is uh [ __ ] it's weird
cause you re-watch some of those movies
like man he really made
great movies like spotlight was one of
his last ones you're like that's a
[ __ ]
incredible movie the tarantino movies
then
then you read about him you're like
you're the worst [ __ ]
you're the worst what is it about these
like these guys who do good work like
cosby was known as the best comedian of
all time for a while and then he's a
psycho
no no doctor but no jew
yeah no it's just the weirdest thing
like you hear picasso's is brilliant
artist but he's also like a wife beater
or whatever it is so it's
a pretty weird kind of extremes that
these guys live in
well i think if you're used to getting
away with [ __ ] massive success ain't
gonna
ain't gonna make you stop yeah yeah i
guess so
good point and also weinstein i mean
look at the guy he's a [ __ ] he
probably was a horny [ __ ] who
couldn't get laid then he got all this
power and was like i still can't get
laid
right you're right i know and then you
hear all these stories but him and
epstein had like weird dongs where they
were like deformed and twisted
so you're like egg-shaped yeah
hitler with the one ball one ball and
apparently a hitler to tiny dong as well
oh interesting we're seeing a pattern
we have huge dogs thank god our dicks
aren't egg shaped
exactly that's a weird shape by the way
yeah yeah that's tough because you want
some girth but
it's no good without the link you don't
want a tuna can no one wants their dick
to be described as hard-boiled
what did it look like uh you know
poached i don't know
[Laughter]
it's such a weird uh thing hit ron on
head our boy ron on hershberg had such a
great tweet
about uh i don't want a victim shame but
i feel like eva braun really ignored a
lot of red flags about hitler
ah that's great so true
[ __ ] i mean just those those knights are
in the pillow talk i can only imagine
what he was saying
that'd be great if he was like really
shy in bed if he was just like
he's like oh shucks i don't he was i
mean there were there were the gay
rumors too
obviously oh well you know the obsession
i mean when you're obsessing
over men's looks and the whole aryan
thing enough it's kind of like
all right there might be some [ __ ] going
on yeah i mean
just the the sheer numbers like you'd
have to think some slave owners back in
the day were probably like damn look at
the dong on that
that slave because like obviously there
had to be gay
slave owners just with the statistics
sure sure and they [ __ ] they all
sounded like lindsey graham
they all had the same delivery but uh
you're right
what uh give me a give me a wreck all
right all right i'm glad you asked there
because i feel like i've been throwing
out 12 documentaries a week and i got a
minute i started
one of them i started the operation
odessa i'm like halfway through i'm
going to finish it tonight
i loved it i love docs
like that where it's just insanity it's
a great recommendation i can't wait to
finish it
it's it's such a cool doc because it's
so over the top but it's real
so it's not like oh the writers went too
far it's like i can't believe it's all
true
that's fun all right so i've been
recommending a lot of movies and docs
and all that stuff i'm mixing it up
a band i love that i don't think is
getting any any recognition
or at least i'm out of the music game so
maybe i'm i'm an idiot but uh
dr dog i'm thrilled about this
are they huge yeah aren't they i think
they're huge harry we're invited to us
are they not huge doctor dog they're out
of philly like every
one banger after another they're kind of
mellow but they can all
the lyrics are really smart and
interesting so i'm just i'm going doctor
dog i put it on when i write i put on
the car
i love it dr dog i'm looking them up
yeah they're big
i don't know yeah all right maybe not
look i'm not a big music guy in terms of
like knowing new bands and stuff and i
know them so
that's you know i've heard their stuff
they're great they're they're very good
love them love them just kind of mellow
but really really talented musicians big
big fan of dr
d and uh i think they like this kind of
mid-level career i think that's
feels like that's the new new hot spot
of famous
you don't want to be kim k and you don't
want to be nobody
i like a nice middle ground like a bert
chrysler level or a bill burr or
something like that
arenas is your middle ground billboard
plays the garden dude
good point good point whoa
little bigger than mike you're right
though you're right about like
the not having to worry about like
paparazzi
and having a good middle class career
which you kind of can as an entertainer
now you couldn't back in the day i feel
like but that's true but now it's like
yeah you have a good
solid you know financial career but
you're not
you don't have to worry about just you
know
i don't know i mean there's going to be
there's going to be [ __ ] at every level
i feel like
but the bigger you get it just seems
like you have a target on your back
yeah completely and look you have these
high heights and it's probably great you
reach the mountain top but the
the level of [ __ ] is also equal to the
greatness and i'd rather
maybe i'm not i'm too weak i'd rather
just a nice middle [ __ ] and a middle
greatness
i don't want to be ellen that's insane
or kevin hart i can't even imagine
that's
going to be a nightmare but you're right
with the internet you can kind of hover
and be a nice
b squad and that's that's good enough
for me i don't want to be ellen
because that [ __ ] it just looks like
not real like what she's doing
like i mean her coming out and like
dancing with people and i'm like i know
you're not a good
person like there's no way you're like a
there's no way that you're that cool and
then like every member of her staff is
like she's horrible and it's like yes
so you've created this world where
you're this like fun as like that's not
a fun person
right right completely we know you're
not fun i mean i look i respect that she
[ __ ]
is cut throat and played the game and
you know lesbian in the 90s sitcom like
couldn't have been easy but but like
enough with this [ __ ]
ruse that you're you know yeah if you're
throwing out with the
the dancing to me is like no [ __ ]
comic is dancing
exactly yeah nice people are just they
just kind of hang back and be nice they
don't have to
it's almost like the guy who hates gays
but he's actually gay you know
right she's coming out and dancing
you're like you're actually a [ __ ] like
but then you got
then you got a what's his face james
gandolfini he's just hanging back
smoking cigars he's giving the whole
cast
his pay he's the greatest the great
keanu reeves another one you just never
you never hear [ __ ] about him like he's
just a great dude
right now basically any straight white
man
is just a great guy and uh he's half
filipino i think
i'm [ __ ] around no i uh i love uh
i love gandolfini so much ellen is like
look i've just heard horror stories that
she's not
nice to her employees and it's like you
[ __ ] made it you did it you're making
stupid money
you live in a probably troy mcclure type
[ __ ] floating palace that overlooks
the hills or whatever
like you're not gonna [ __ ] be nice to
people be [ __ ] nice to people
i completely agree and look i get some
of the arguments like you always hear
these things like jlo
it's in her it's in her writer you can't
look her in the eye and all that [ __ ]
you're like wow that's crazy
and obviously that's silly but sometimes
i understand the
the amount of effort and energy a person
has you can't always give that away
to strangers you got to save it for the
stage or save it for the camera
no people do take for sure where you're
like i'll say this i [ __ ] had to work
all day
uh you know on a very [ __ ] minor
level i had to work all day and then we
drove every night to do gigs in jersey
and you know stress factory and that
tent shows amazing setup love the stress
factory
great great club after the show
i'm exhausted you know it's one showdown
i'm trying to recharge in the green room
and there's no one working the door
there so someone just knocks in the door
i assume it's the waiter so i'm like oh
yeah come in it's [ __ ] dudes from the
show they're like yo
and i'm just like i'm like oh hey man
like we do a picture i was like yeah
right it's like eight dudes and i'm just
like yeah
and then they're like taking forever and
i said guys come on [ __ ]
so i'm sure they could be like he's an
[ __ ] but i'm like speed just take the
[ __ ] picture i'm trying to relax
right i have to do another [ __ ] hour
15 on the on the late show i've been
working all day i drove here i gotta
drive back i'm tired
of course of course but i don't think i
don't think
that it was like that with that one from
what i heard i heard she did not have
her staff's back
oh that's different that's different
yeah that's [ __ ] up
i don't know yeah these are your staff
you hired them they're working for you
you want them to like you
yeah that being said you got to give i
mean like it's
it's i think there's there's
there's nuance to this where being a
woman in the clubs in the 90s could not
have been
in the 80s even she was a [ __ ] hater
she's been out for in the 80s you were a
[ __ ]
woman on the road like that wasn't easy
sure
yeah a lot of like hey sweetie ass slap
pain or less you know uh yeah am i gonna
[ __ ] the opener she's the opener she's a
woman she'll [ __ ] that's all that's all
that [ __ ] i'm sure
well they hate to deal with [ __ ] in the
80s was like if i have a bad set they're
not booking a woman again
you know yeah those are the good
yeah yeah it's true that's probably
right that's gotta be rough and she did
carson
and carson was like they did panel he
was like it's got to be tough being a
woman she's like you have no idea
well that was even as a kid i saw that
and i was like really and i like sunk in
and it's not like she's not funny like
she is funny she was a good comic
great comic uh so you know but
be nice that's all i'm saying be nice to
people
you're here yeah it's it's easy to be
nice and like
i get it when you're like a guy look i
even i i don't think i was rude to those
people but like
that's a moment where i'm like oh they
could probably tell people that i was
like a little like
cranky but i'm just like guys i'm just
like i'm you came into my green room
where i'm chilling
and hiding right well you have more
self-respect
because i would just do all the pictures
the hugs the high fives
and i wouldn't want to do it but i would
do it and then i would just wait it out
and they would
even i'd be like but you actually you
did the right thing
you stood up for yourself and said hey
you know this is all you i'm getting
nothing out of this and this is
one-sided help me
out i'm happy to take a picture with
[ __ ] anyone i'm i'm
shocked it's like you know we've been
doing this for a long time so you're so
shocked that anyone wants to take a
picture with you you're still like holy
[ __ ] i
can't believe that means something to
someone but at the same time like
come on man and if i'm if you're coming
into my [ __ ] area where i'm hiding
just like just
have a little respect of course of
course yeah and
a little awareness you know i'm trying
to recharge
now what do you do for this one because
i get this one a lot i never know how to
act the guy who comes up he's got you in
the headlock and he goes
i love you man you can smell the whiskey
and he goes i drove four hours to get
him
oh my god thank you so much i can't
believe he did that
and then it's quiet and he's almost kind
of like that's it i drove four hours to
see you and you said thanks
that's i'm like well what do you want me
to do make you a sandwich i don't know
what to do here
i gave you a show you leave i mean this
is your choice there's a line in the
dangerfield documentary
where adam sandler is telling this story
and he goes i meet rodney he's my
favorite comedian ever and he goes up
and goes rodney you're my favorite
comedian of all time and ronnie goes hey
i'll tell you thanks you know
and and he goes that's it and dangerous
goes what do you want me to do a [ __ ]
cartwheel
it's true it's true i mean i appreciate
it i just i don't know what to do give
you gas money i mean
why you don't say you just say thank you
so much if you guess what
it just never feels like a no you just
say thank you so much man it means a lot
that you i think you go
what can you say except i'm i'm so
grateful that you would you would drive
that far to see me tell my dumb jokes i
mean it's you know
you just you're grateful you're just
like i thank you so much man i can't
imagine
all right i can because i took a [ __ ]
flight here but
uh no no no you say i i can't i'm you
say you're grateful because you are i
mean it i am
it is very appreciative it is incredible
i guess
but it's incredible that anyone would go
so funny the first [ __ ] night i'm on
stage with at the stretch factory in
jersey
and vinnie brand the owner comes on i
don't know he's going to come on she
just starts like he's like hey come back
and riff with me i was like yeah what
the [ __ ] why not so
we're talking on stage and vinnie goes
uh so uh you know you're gonna you're
gonna come back to the club right and
i'm just like
i'm here the whole weekend what do you
what do you think i'm do you think i'm
just bailing on you
yeah yeah what do you mean you're gonna
come back did the same thing to me he's
like
all these they get too big they never
come back romano
seinfeld chris i'm like well what do you
want to do do a weekend here every night
like
they're doing theaters i think rock does
go back i think rock will
like work out there because he lives in
jersey oh yeah yeah he'll probably work
out there and do like a
[ __ ] what do you call it like oscars
or something
romano's in the new scorsese movie he's
like come back to [ __ ] the stress
factories like right
i know i know but it's a great club it's
a great club and vinnie's
vinnie's a great dude and they're
actually like they put up a tent and
[ __ ] that works it's incredible it's
like heated you're not cold it's
it's insane you put like 80 grand into
what i heard yeah and it's paying off
it's one of the best uh
setups in the country i think i've done
a lot of outdoor stuff and
maybe it is the best and they run it
beautifully and it kind of feels like a
community there like the club the crowds
feel like they know vinnie he knows the
crowds he's saying hi to everybody
it's a cool thing i love it it's yeah it
was it feels great to
be telling jokes man i miss it so
[ __ ] much so anytime
i just miss our regular way of life like
doing this every night and hanging at
the clubs and
i mean even this is [ __ ] weirdly just
like
like i look forward to this where we're
just like having a drink and shooting
this [ __ ] it's like kind of nice
you know it's necessary totally
necessary and uh like you go to a green
room
i'm at the stress factor in the green
room with an opener ian laura
and i didn't want to leave like he's
like we gotta get back it's midnight i'm
like
a little longer you know we gotta we got
a chicken sandwich coming in we got
vodka
whiskey sodas let's hang out yeah i was
doing tequila
my thing is i'll do coffee on the early
show and i'll do tequila in the late
and i'll do like tequila with lime it's
like kind of
hangover proof it's kind of great i love
it that's my go-to as well
all you need is that squeeze of lime
it's a beautiful lime and you're good
little aviano casamigos or some [ __ ] and
you're like
[ __ ] i'm good dude yeah they say it
has to be a clear tequila so watch out
with that ground stuff
yeah i go clear or gold i mean but yeah
yeah yeah yeah no i'm with you i i don't
do the
i mean if you want to have like some
monejo or some [ __ ] that's it's pretty
good but you're gonna you're gonna feel
it a little more the next day
there was one night at the cellar where
me you and a couple other guys
just did casamigos straight up for i
don't know
nine hours and we woke up we swung the
door open
the sun shines in we fall out on the
sidewalk you you fall into a cab
we win i walk home i haven't been that
hung over
since the 80s i mean the next day i was
like regarding henry i was like trying
to feed myself i was drooling
oh that was the worst hangover of all
time i remember
we would always have that like late
afternoon text
you know i think we'd be like we're like
not talking to people until then i'd be
like
you're hurting and you'd be like i'm
[ __ ] hurting you're almost like
grateful that it's not just you that's
in that much game
where you're like all right exactly
we're in this together i guess it's
funny how much [ __ ] like
we bring that [ __ ] in ourselves but it's
like every once in a while you just need
that [ __ ] talk or that vent sesh where
you're just like
[ __ ] everything and you feel
good and so now those hangovers because
you just turned into like the most
primal vert you're like need to eat
[ __ ] water sleep you know you got a skid
mark going
you got to order in uh like a hamburger
i mean it's the saddest version of you
of all time
drip drop do you do that pedialyte any
of that stuff ah i love pedialyte
game changer i can just show if i'm
hungover enough i'll just chug the whole
carton of it and my body you can feel it
going in your body's like yep
this is good we need this we got an ad
we got to give you too
uh lucy's nicotine gum good call
these [ __ ] are great i mean if
you're struggling if you're struggling
with
uh cigarette smoking this will get you
off founded by caltech scientists
former smokers who want to help other
people quit and it actually has it
actually tastes good it's like
wintergreen and pomegranate flavors
cinnamon
four four milligrams of nicotine and uh
you know i mean this is what it's all
about man like the if you're trying to
get off cigarettes the best time to get
off it especially with covid
you know respiratory illness uh unless
you don't i mean
i guess there's some if you're in jersey
maybe not because you get the vaccine
first if you're a cigarette smoker
good point but you know they're
supporting the show
so go support them get 20 of all
products including gum
or lozenges at lucy.co with code drunk
you get 20 off with code drunk at
lucy.co
promo code drunk at checkout and here's
part uh here's the part the lawyers make
us
a warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco nicotine is an
addictive chemical
but you already knew that so just go get
20 off at lucy.co
with code drunk yes get on it today it
tastes great and they have lozenges
if you don't like gum but look kovit
this is your time to make yourself
better you got all the free time in the
world quit smoking
grab some gum and you know because
nicotine ain't bad for you it's just
the actual cigarette tar and all that
rat
[ __ ] they put in there so get the gum
get healthy
live your life longer what uh what
okay i mean this is an obvious one but
i've i've restarted the whole show again
so i gotta
soprano season one man i have to i hate
to be a [ __ ] cliche but i'm
rewatching the whole show
and i've rewatched the show probably 12
times i'm obsessed with it
but i've i mean it's like my
sopranos is my go-to because it's
weirdly for such a violent show it's
weirdly
common because it's so it's so funny
it's so
uh well written like that's the only
thing i was
i was watching one uh today i just like
i went for
you know i went for iran i was like
listening to it and
it's so [ __ ] funny dude it's so it
was like
uh uncle junior the way he [ __ ] talks
and is like
this old man but he's just a [ __ ]
they find out this
kid he knew his taylor's kid uh
overdosed and like crashed a car
and he's like this guy's still selling
drugs and junior just goes and what's
this
motherless [ __ ] name
like like every once in a while they
have to do some personal [ __ ] you know
and then it just cuts the junior in the
nursing home with tony's mom
and he goes ugh even the coffee's old
here ah
he's great he's the funniest one and
that mom was
such a coos like i i would see her in a
scene and i would get uncomfortable she
would she was incredible
she was so good dude junior my buddy uh
rhys waters who's like a
great dude he's like a sportscaster now
he did a couple letterman's back in the
day he's funny and he's like a great
dude
and i knew him since i started and he uh
yeah he was telling me he played pool
with
at the friars club in new york he played
pool with a junior soprano once
uh dominic and uh he said
one of the nicest [ __ ] you'll
ever meet i was like ah it just makes
you you're just like happy that that's
how it goes you know yeah yeah oh man
that dude is it corrado corrado soprano
yeah
what a great name yeah he's a badass i
mean you're probably still in the early
seasons right
i'm back on season one but i've
rewatched the entire show
so many times six is a harder re-watch
for me because it gets so bleak
yeah when [ __ ] starts going downhill
it's kind of like how like the first
you know hour 50 of wolf of wall street
is a ton of fun and then you're kind of
like
ah this last hour 10 is kind of rough i
don't know
right right right it's like elvis's life
you know
this is unbelievable and then got to him
dead on a toilet with a you know peanut
butter and banana sandwich
it's like anyone's life yeah i guess so
but man jackie
you jackie jr when he comes in and then
when uh
chris is all like hopped up on dope that
is the saddest [ __ ]
what that intervention scene i still say
is one of the funniest
written scenes i've ever seen in
television i'm with you
he sits on cozette and tony's obsessed
with animal he's like
you sit on a [ __ ] dog you didn't feel
it under you how do you kill a dog
and then he calls his mom a [ __ ] so uh
paulie punches him i mean
i'm on the floor paulie's yelling at him
you're weak you're weak
the [ __ ] intervention it's [ __ ]
gold
i assume most people watching us have
seen the sopranos but if you haven't
seen the sopranos
watch the sopranos it's [ __ ] it's
perfect it's a perfect show
brilliant it's got something for
everybody and i'd say the best character
development on tv
every character is so there's so much
depth
yeah to the point where you know what
movies they like that's a good point
i mean gary cooper and [ __ ] tony
watching like
he's watching like white heat at one
point with an agony and you're just like
oh this is
so many great little the writers are so
smart where you're like oh man like i'm
i'm learning [ __ ] i just rewatched the
one where he takes meadow to uh
to college one of the greatest episodes
in tv history he
takes meadow to look at schools and he
runs into a guy
who's in witness protection who used to
be in the mob and tony [ __ ]
kills oh yeah yeah it's crazy it's so
it's so layered where you're like oh you
it's that no show
gets like a sociopath and then also
shows
the family man where you're like
even with aj where he's just like
finding out what his dad does and tony
just [ __ ]
he's at the funeral for uh jackie april
and tony just winks at him and you're
like
[ __ ] i would want his approval too yeah
yeah
totally totally it's it's true because
it's so real i mean we're we're
humans with ego and insecurities it's
it's [ __ ]
ah i'm sorry to give an obvious record
that's what i've been watching again
so i will finish i will finish operation
odessa you got to watch rick and morty
that's
you got to go oh i got to watch that i
got to watch that oh good
i struggle with cartoons but i don't
know why i love this but you're working
on it
i love family guy what yeah no you're
working on a cartoon and you
and you uh and you just said
like three or three that you love you
know yeah no it's all me but
everybody tells me i sound like that guy
like like rick
yeah because you burp when you talk oh
is that what it is
he burps when he talks a lot oh all
right i'll tell you yeah he's
i mean dude he said rick from rick and
morty is like the best character yeah
you'll i want to hear what you say
you'll come back on a pod
and we'll we'll rehash that one point
what give me a pet peeve oh oh bojack is
another good cartoon too bojack's good
bojacks [ __ ]
it gets sad it gets i couldn't finish it
i was like i don't wanna i'm assuming
then sadly i don't i don't wanna
it puts me in a bad place but i did like
bojack oh yeah
all right pet peeve i got i got two but
one of them is better i want to i wrote
it down i want to say it right
okay i'm gonna try to recreate this
because it happens to me all the time
and i [ __ ]
can't stand it all right when you mix up
two things on
accident and people dwell on it you know
you go uh
well you know uh new york city is the
capital of new york and albany's the
best city
in new york and they go oh wait hold on
i mean albany's the capital and you and
they go
oh jesus for a second i thought you
thought albany was the best city in new
york
no you the new york city is the capital
of all but he's a cap i'm like i know i
caught it i changed
you really to new york the capitol
i got it wrong for two seconds i know
the answer i just and then they just
keep hammering it on you i'm like
this is all you got you can't come up
with anything on your own so you got a
[ __ ] on my point that wasn't even good
i'm so with you it's like it's like you
almost need to retake a scene in a movie
and the director's like nope you only
got one chance at it and we're going
with that you're a shitty actor now
that's a great way to put it yeah you're
like uh robert de niro was in star wars
and harrison four wasn't good i mean
harrison four was in star wars you think
harrison ford was in good fellas like no
no i corrected myself
no no backsies
your friends like they just they want
you to be wrong so bad and then you go
no i'm showing you that i know and they
go i don't i don't care that you know i
want to just [ __ ] with you
oh that's so [ __ ] funny that's so
true i hate that i [ __ ] hate that
hate it they won't leave it alone that's
a good one because that drives me nuts
we had a funny thing i mean we talked
about once when we were doing clubs on
the road early on and like how that free
meal meant so much to us
and you did a club in ohio and the guy's
like get the salmon
yeah and you were like oh and they
charged you for it yeah funny farm in
youngstown ohio never forget
he was upselling me he's like a great
wine to get with this swordfish is the
red i was like all right bring it on and
then
800 later you know yeah that happened to
me in a club
called loonies with two e's in colorado
springs i'm not bragging but i uh i did
a gig
uh and all week he's like you can have a
drink oh my god i don't know he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] the bartender and i'm like
yeah all right i'll have a drink i'm
like a young
comic on the road and then they [ __ ]
hand me a bill for all the beers at the
end of the weekend i'm like you [ __ ]
pricks
what a douche you're making me i know
yeah brutal how is colorado spring that
seems like a
pretty town it's like a naval base uh
town it's it's cute it's like all right
i mean it's uh
remember i went to a mexican restaurant
dude it was great it was it was cool i
mean like the club wasn't great
i think they have a big i could be wrong
but i think they have a big vietnamese
population too
uh it was yeah it was good it was it was
i mean the club
i think the crowds were like pretty nice
it's just the club kind of sucked and i
was a young
comic on the road i remember taking a
picture
i liked clubs that have all the head
shots up and it had
like young louis black young everyone uh
boy nick griffin so i took a picture of
him he's super young black and white
photo
and he goes why would you [ __ ] send
this to me
that's so romantic to think about those
guys you know there's still some fire in
their belly you know there's some hunger
and they're going out to cholera these
east coast guys like i'm going to
colorado springs whatever the [ __ ] that
is
they just wanted to get up [ __ ] all i
miss it so much the
the regularity of it but uh my pet peeve
is
this is a dumb one but when people are
running late and
uh they're running late and then they're
like all right i'm like 20 minutes out
but they're more than 20 minutes out
and it's like yeah i'm gonna find out
just tell me don't make me
you're gonna you and then they're like
oh it's like there's traffic i'm like
you're running late from running late
now right right
so i i'm just i i got look if you're
late you're late
uh but don't [ __ ] lie how late
because then sometimes you're waiting
for the person on the street or
something i hate that [ __ ]
it's it's bad news and i've done it i'm
guilty of it where you go
i'm getting on the train right now and
you haven't left your house i've done it
and i
feel horrible every time but you're
right it's a shitty move because
you're gonna the proof is in the pudding
you're gonna show up late and then
it's not gonna add up yeah i'm with you
man it's just kind of like uh
just [ __ ] tell me i i because i don't
care that much i try to be on time i
think
punctuality is like you realize how
important that [ __ ] is as you get older
too where you're like yeah you're
[ __ ] with people's time
you're right this is their their you
don't know how busy people are know
what's going on in their life
that's the other thing like you don't
you don't know what people are going
through right now so just be respectful
like i talked to a friend the other day
i haven't talked to forever
and he told me this [ __ ] horrible
story about his wife and i'm like
oh i didn't know that like you don't
know what's going on and
yeah in people's lives so be [ __ ]
punctual and respectful to people you
know [ __ ]
yeah and the worst is when they're super
late and you're like alright well i got
a heart out and then they
show up and you're like well now we only
have this much time and they get mad at
you like what why not
you're like oh my god if you were on
time
i love that when you agree to do
something you don't want to do and then
they're late and then you're like all
right well i still got to leave at this
time they're like oh come
on you're like [ __ ] right right it's one
of my favorite todd barry jokes when uh
he's like
you ever have someone make plans with
you and you don't really want to do it
and they cancel oh he's like oh sorry i
can't meet back up i'll be
i'm too busy dancing in the streets oh
[ __ ] that's great
you know what else i i on on a
piggybacking on your late thing
a pet peeve please i was hanging out my
friend's house i'm back in new orleans
so i'm seeing some old
high school douches and the guy
i'm at his parents house and his mom's
going hey lunch is ready come on down
he's going i'm coming he's upset i'm
coming and she's like okay
and then he's like still doing stuff and
she's like hello lunch she's like i'm
coming mom
it's like no you're not she's calling
you you keep saying you're going
but you're not moving oh it was driving
me crazy i'm like she's right i'm with
her
damn what a [ __ ] prick oh yeah i feel
like kids do that to them
he's living at home huh is he living at
home oh he's
a [ __ ] loser yeah he's uh he's a drug
addict guy he's a great dude he's cool
as [ __ ]
but yeah
he's fun he's a fun guy he's on pills
and stuff that's so [ __ ] a fun guy
it's so [ __ ] funny well
i feel like him not coming down to lunch
on time is the least of his [ __ ]
mom's worries
yeah yeah yeah what about the oxycodone
or whatever he's uh does he do that [ __ ]
well he's got he's got all kinds he's
got like a jar of filled looks like
mints and candy and you're like oh
that's a
car that's a xanax that's a whatever it
is
purple football you name it fun guy it's
funny the pills
like that people take when they get
cause i've noticed a lot of like older p
when you're younger you take like
uh you know speed coke [ __ ] that like
gives you energy and [ __ ] but
when you get older it's all [ __ ] that
slows you down like ambient yeah
like it's all it's also you're like 7
p.m i'm [ __ ] tapping out you know
what i mean
that's so true it's like yeah you go to
college and everybody's doing adderall
they're all snorting it they're all
popping it
and then yeah you get older and
everybody's like give me a [ __ ] xanax
or a kalanapan i wanna
i wanna conk out on this flight
yeah you kinda want less time as you get
older or you're at least more like
you kind of know when to dip out i think
that's part of being older like when
you're younger you're like i'll [ __ ]
be up for i'll be up till 7 a.m but then
you're older you're like i'll get up at
7 a.m
yeah yeah you don't want your time to to
coincide with that [ __ ] when
you're older
yes and you could say the same with
sleep i mean look at kids they never
want to go to sleep then they want to
wake up early and as an adult you're
like i'm dying to crash i'm dying to
sleep in
i got to get a nap in sleep
yeah yeah you it's like weird i was
driving to the gig with
shafi he drove a buddy shafi hussein and
uh
i would he could see i see i was like
exhausted he was like dude conk out for
a second and i just passed out in the
car for like five minutes and i felt so
much better
that's a good guy right there like the
nap car guy
i don't i never am that guy i always
fight through it but like especially end
of the night because i'm like oh i'm
going home i'll [ __ ] coffee up
whatever but like
pre-show i'm like i i'm not gonna have
it if i don't
i and that's the first time i've done it
in forever years you know yeah
but no one they say like a six minutes
of napping can
really boost you like 80 it's totally
worth it
yeah that's wild what uh what do you
what do you got for news stories
oh oh yeah yeah yeah well i was gonna
throw out my uh super bowl
tweet it's so good that was so relevant
all right let me just uh hopefully uh
nobody gets mad about this but hey [ __ ]
it
uh who's getting mad i don't know people
like who love brady or hate cobit
oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] dude i know i know
everybody's mad about something
they're joking but also like we've said
we respect the guy like we can't make
jokes he's the [ __ ] greatest ever you
can't [ __ ] make a comment
good point all right here we go today is
the super bowl so
it's topical tom brady is the covet of
football
he's thriving in florida he's put up
huge numbers
and some people still don't believe in
him that's a great joke
that's like a [ __ ] perfect late night
joke yeah we got
uh we got 700 retweets so we're cooking
that's great i i had an idea for brady
as like maybe it's like how
i saw an interview we was asked if uh he
and gisele ever have sex on game day
and he said i would never say it's it's
i wouldn't say it's never happened but
you know it's not the time you know it's
time for prep
i like that i like the just image of
giselle trying to bang him and he's like
not now
i'm thinking about gronk you know what i
mean
yeah yeah i gotta watch game film the
other
idea is like about how brady and gisele
met on a blind date in 2006.
ah but like i don't like that it's
called a blind date cause it's like
you know what they look like yeah right
right you're both on the cover of
magazines it's not a blind date
yeah i mean we've all showed up to a
blind date and you're like oh my god
she's attractive thank god imagine being
like oh my gosh she's a supermodel
yeah like no one's going on like you're
like i'm going on a blind date with kate
upton
i hope she's pretty you know [ __ ] just
yeah yeah
exactly hope you got huge cans
jesus look at those knobs what do you
got for um
from yours oh those are my those are my
ideas for the news
okay okay super bowl oh right all right
yeah that's great and
here's another quick one this is the
stupidest me another
peta wants you to stop using animal
slurs like pig or
chicken and i said uh peter's getting a
little squirrely
all right there's your tweet folks
now we're getting depth with this nike
has unveiled their first hands-free
shoes
that uh not hands-free for the chinese
boy who
sewed it up all right we're moving on
not a handshake for the chinese that's
strong
good all right you got a bit i had one
other that was like a riff last night
but it was just like a riff
on uh the super bowl they were like uh
mahomes are brady and i said well it's
basically the you know it's basically
the 2008 election it's a cool young
black guy versus an old white
oh that's good off the cuff it killed uh
i don't know if it's a great connection
let's see um yeah give me a bit
that you're working on well i feel bad
because
i'm two weeks in a row with a trans bit
but i think i got something here
okay chappelle
[Laughter]
it's pro it's pro i mean i'm [ __ ]
around
all right so but i think i got a big i
got a big angle here and i'm
getting on stage it worked but it's
still
wonky okay
it sounds just sounds like a trans
person decided to uh talking about their
piece i've got a big angle it's wonky
yeah it still works right
i think you'll like it if you give it a
chance please
um all right so trans women are now
playing
sports with biological women and
dominating
yeah and a lot of people are upset about
this and it must be how white guys felt
in the 40s when blackfield started
playing like we can't allow this we'll
never win again
it's unnatural that's [ __ ] great
all right and nobody gets hurt now you
know it's not really you can't really
get offended by it
yeah what's her name jack robinson
that's not a [ __ ] woman
right right they're not the same as us
jacqueline robinson
hey that's good i like that
um it's a great premise
um needs more but i think that's the
well the primary yeah two of these that
i've
pitched on you that you helped me with
are working now so oh yeah
my friend had a great idea eric he said
we should
shoot this and then shoot the bit
working on stage
oh that's fun yeah that's cool
yeah i love it um i mean we've been
doing this for years
my idea was on um have you seen the
documentary the brooklyn 7-5
i love it it's about the most corrupt
precinct in uh new york history it's
hilarious
first off i love documentaries that are
like
people who just clearly it's like the
odessa guy clearly have not learned
their lesson like they're reminiscing
about this [ __ ] like it's still cool
and they're like would i change anything
nah and you're like
you're an unemployable divorced loser
like you wouldn't
change anything but so basically for the
uh
for the [ __ ] bit was that uh
they they're talking about the uh
precinct and they're like it was the
scariest precinct ever
anyone would have been scared it would
have scared clint eastwood and i'm like
oh you mean a 97 year old actor
he would have no one would have [ __ ]
with us not uh dustin hoffman
not uh not meryl streep no one
that's great that's great police academy
knowing the police steve guttenberg
the sound effect guy the sound of that
guy
that's great you couldn't say dirty
harry
exactly clint is hilarious amy loves an
old man who wears
makeup and goes to a set yes yes
exactly by the way still [ __ ] kicking
man
incredible i know i know he looks good
too he looks great
i saw a movie with my ex-girlfriend she
was like he's kind of hot i'm like all
right take it easy there
filthy but uh he's a handsome man
handsome man great
just like a what do you call it a tight
skin like
you know a lot of people get that loose
skin he's tight as a drum but
the guy who directed seven five also
directed operation on nasa and the night
stalker
wow i just watched nightstalk on your
rack oh yeah tiller russell he's fun
that [ __ ] is that motherfucker's
creepy
they're just dead behind the eyes man
they're just like you're like this
dude's got nothing
back here nothing nothing and again
pre-dna they were going off a shoe print
[ __ ] crazy yeah they find it's
hilarious that like
they find a [ __ ] like a boot imprint
and they're like we got him
it's like that's how [ __ ] primitive
you did crazy
i know and people were tough back then
like it's california in the 80s or
whatever
some guy gets shot in the face and
chases the dude out
yeah i think you're just in shock and
you're just like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
but that was good
there's that one part where they're like
yeah if i got chased by a dude i shot in
the face
i'd be scared too and you're like yeah i
guess so yeah good point good point and
i love
that these cops are chasing for years
literally years
and then a [ __ ] dude on the street
beats the [ __ ] out of him with a lead
pipe
i'm like yeah a little street justice
you see these kids though it's like we
should [ __ ] there should be like
tests for
kids who would look deranged like that
because like you're dead behind the eyes
at like seven
yeah there's got to be some sort of
treatment and rehab because like you
can't just let that kid keep going
i know i know but what are you gonna do
hey hey
uh the teacher comes on the loudspeaker
uh hey billy johnson you look [ __ ]
creepy can you come in here
yeah like how do you regulate that you
throw him in a cage he lives like he
drinks water like a guinea pig out of a
bottle
and you poke him with a stick till he
[ __ ] snaps out of it i don't know
i think we're doing that to the border
but
you know i like that my idea is the
worst idea trump ever [ __ ] had i'm
like
this is what we do right we separated
from his parents
we put him in a cage
exactly no but these kids really need
like like
well he and then also you're like they
were saying like every [ __ ] idea
like every bad thing that could have
happened happened to him but like
exactly
isn't it kind of cool though and it's
gonna sound horrible but
much much like a superhero origin you
know this guy was a
he got hit with radiation or gamma rays
and he became the hulk
if you do the negative version of gamma
rays they will become a villain
yeah that makes sense no i know you mean
like
without fail like it
your best case gonna make them
emotionally [ __ ] worst case
you you're creating like a [ __ ] super
villain yeah yeah super villain
best case comedian
you know molesting beating you know all
that [ __ ]
they used to keep them in a closet for a
day i mean all kinds of [ __ ]
or best cases serial killer worst case
comedian however there we go
either way you get on netflix
the the shitty serial killers they gotta
[ __ ] they have to self-produce their
documentaries you're like it's on
[ __ ] youtube this is [ __ ]
that joke of yours i remember when i
first heard it
at the fat black sitting on the stairs i
think you were running it for recording
oh yeah that that's such a great joke
about the serial killers are there
serial killers at home
watching serial killers on tv going this
guy sucks
yes that's so good what a great angle i
[ __ ] yeah i [ __ ]
yeah they're watching pissed off like we
are like this [ __ ]
i'm a way better murderer than this guy
yeah
two kills i've been doing this for years
yeah
it's funny i was watching that with
becky owen and we both went damn
oh mike's the best such a [ __ ] great
comedy
guy you did a track on his on his album
right
yeah yeah oh that took so long i know i
was
there we both lip synced uh
a track i've never done this before it
was really hard you're like [ __ ] that's
hard but we both
mark and i both lip synced the track for
mike vecchi owns
what it's for the worst kind of
thoughtfuls album yes
yes incredible album great album both of
us that would
that one and uh muscle mem no muscle
confusion muscle confusion they're both
great but i think
i think worse kind of thoughtful even
took it like because i had that ten
minute
megabus bit where you're like [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
that's poetry he's a beast
by the way not not to get to 80s but
whenever something is really good we say
oh it's poetry
but poetry sucks
nobody likes poetry but yet everything's
like oh the way he swings that golf club
it's poetry
well i think poetry at its best is
incredible
at its worst and that's kind of what
comedy is
ah good point good point at its best
you're like [ __ ]
i'll hear a great song lyric and be like
that's poetic but if i
but you hear like bad music and you're
just like ugh like this is
bad anything but like especially comedy
is yes
bad music you can kind of tune out bad
comedy bad
magic i feel like that's just sad you
see a baby's like a 48 year old guy he's
divorced and he's doing like the rings
these
four rings gotta when they fall apart
you're like oh this poor guy's family
left him
you're in vegas at like one of the sea
rooms you know
uh which we've played but
uh wait you had something there that i
wanted to go [ __ ]
oh when i was in college i took a trip
to chicago with my girlfriend i was like
oh let's see chicago we've never been
and we went to an improv show
at second city it was unbelievable
people showed have all day long has a
lot of bad impact obviously but when you
see good improv
it is i mean it's poetry did anyone
believe it
it's publisher that's going to be a
catchphrase for the pod
what do you remember when any of the
guys go on to be big because
that's a big uh you know chicago improv
so many of the greats came out of there
farley right mike myers vince vaughn
yeah yeah i think some went to like the
groundlings and then worked their way up
into
movies and stuff like that like a lot of
sick comedy stuff i don't know their
names but
i mean these guys were i was on the edge
of my seat my jaw was on the floor like
how did they think of that that was so
quick that was brilliant
you're lost in the scene you feel like
you know we're on the moon now and you
felt like
you bought it it totally worked and
everything i would shout out a thing
they would run with it it was
amazing and then you see some improv in
a black box theater in manhattan you're
like i want to kill myself
i want to eat a bullet this is the worst
i've ever seen i'm cringing i'm [ __ ]
blood i hate this
you know what uh that's such a [ __ ]
it's such a funny
that'd be a great improv name eat a
bullet
i did i remember i did a gig in chicago
once and there's that
old forget the name of it i think the
show is called paper machete
and it's uh it's at an old capone bar
you've done this before
yeah it's like uh yes you know yeah yeah
so i did that
gig and it's like a classic cool ass
[ __ ]
old capone bar yeah it's green the
outside is green
yes and it's right by the the l the
train oh i
hit that room it's got a wrap around
roundish bar
i'm looking up right now what it's
called the grandmaster place was amazing
the green mill greenville chicago
[ __ ] club maybe that'll be our
backdrop for one of these episodes
classic
and uh scott adset from 30 rock did
improv
before my set and he was [ __ ]
hilarious he was really really good
yeah mine was a burlesque thing and i
was the comedy it was so cool
and matt broner was there as well it was
fun oh chicago guy i love broner
yeah and uh scott adds it though you're
like [ __ ] this dude he's so funny on 30
rocks so it's just cool to see him
[ __ ] around doing like i love that i
love that it's like when you see like
bill burr pop in on a bar
show you're like oh yeah yes um
we should also plug the patreon man a
lot of we already got almost 200 people
we just started it's uh patreon.com
we might be drunk uh pod and then we
also have a new email
we changed the email because we changed
the name of the pod so it's now we might
be drunk
gmail.com join the patreon we'll read
your emails your pet peeves your wrecks
all that [ __ ] we also got it we got an
ad we got to do
uh you know it might we might be drunk
pod at gmail sorry
thank you harry we might be drunk potted
gmail uh
you know pet peeves rex jokes put it in
the subject we'll read it on the pod
uh you know your drink wrecks maybe
maybe
i i talked to someone after a show it
was in the show uh stress factor and
someone said
we should do uh drink like we should
take drink wrecks from
that should be an episode like they
choose what we drink i was like that
could be fun i don't know
that i mean i like trying new [ __ ] i
feel like i've had the the whole
range on alcohol so if you got a new
idea throw it at us we'll make it
joke premises are great one-liners yeah
you name it so bring it on
in and keep listening to the pod give us
a five-star review we love you guys
we're grateful for you guys
uh you we're having fun doing this so
i'm glad that
you guys are enjoying this uh subscribe
on um
on spotify on apple watch on either on
mark or my
youtube channel uh watch our specials on
youtube
yes and uh and stay safe and we
appreciate you guys
yeah i can't believe we both had bloody
marys
perfect because this that's like a day
drinker pro move
right there yes yes exactly get a little
flavor in there a little little uh
sustenance that's a vegetable right
all right we'll see you next week and
subscribe to the patreon and you get a
second one